après le premier tour des élections
municipales 2020 à rambouillet en mars
dernier véronique matillon candidat
divers droite est en première position
la candidate soutenue par le maire
sortant marc robert devance david jutier
de la liste écologiste à rambouillet en
commun en troisième position on retrouve
gilles schmitt candidats la république
en marche les rangs politain se sont peu
mobilisés sur cette élection la
participation était seulement de 41,26 %
différents enjeux se dégage de ces
élections municipales la commune de 26
mille habitants à une double identité
urbaine et rurale situant clairière de
la forêt de rambouillet la ville
appartient pour sa partie non urbaines
au parc national régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse 77% des espaces
rural à préserver notamment des moyens
de déplacement à repenser la ville
bénéficie également d'un patrimoine
riche avec le château qui date du 15ème
siècle ou encore la bergerie nationale
de structure qui accueille plusieurs
milliers de visiteurs chaque année la
visibilité de ces sites et à développer
votre en jeunes et de la crise sanitaire
liée aux chorales à virus la
conservation des commerces en
centre-ville
plusieurs petits commerces pourraient se
retrouver en difficulté dans les
prochaines années
avant cet épisode le taux d'occupation
des surfaces commerciales et 2 93% et
boutiques vides sont trois fois moins
nombreuses que dans le reste de la
france
enfin la santé sera également un enjeu
sur la commune la ville bénéficie
notamment d'un centre hospitalier la
ville n'est pas encore considérée comme
un désert médical selon les chiffres de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé
une trentaine de médecins sont présents
sur la ville mais ce chiffre est en
baisse de 20% sur dix ans et la moitié
de ses médecins à plus de 55 ans